the first thing has the Bulls island for
a very brief period I thought of
becoming a priest or Christian brother
which maybe and those times young
Catholic women would have thought of
becoming nuns but them and my kiyose
thankfully it was only a passing I've
been trying to find the time to figure
all of that out so that I can get my
considered answer to a question like
that I mean I was I was reared as a
Catholic and I and I still I'm a
Catholic and I attend and and get
comfort from some of the heck the mass
and other Catholic ceremonies but and
increasingly I find myself dealing more
with spirituality reading more about
Buddhism trying to read a wee bit about
Islam starkly in terms of the Christian
churches I'm totally just welded by all
the Muslim on me and I use that term
advisedly denominational differences and
are the old Becker with each other I
think that's all totally against any
sense of what Christ was about so was I
being too judgmental about it at all
as I say I believe increasingly and
people I think there is a spirituality
Ireland as a very spiritual place for me
and a very spiritual a very spiritual
place we used to before they civilized
us we used to believe in trees and the
elements and the pooka and I still
believe in a lot of those things and I
believe in nature as a grid as a grid
elemental force